- I feel like it's interesting,
how quickly your views on someone,
about their personality can change.
- It was cool to meet people,
and then see where they
actually fell on the lineup.
Because I had these other
assumptions already made,
on like where I thought they should be.
- That was kind of almost
like a reality check.
(upbeat music)
- My name is Connor.
I am 21 years old.
I'm from Chicago, Illinois.
- My turn (laughs).
Hi, I'm Claire.
I'm 22.
I'm from Huntington beach, California,
and I'm a recent college graduate.
- Hi, I'm Sierra.
I'm 22.
I'm from Massachusetts,
but I live in LA now.
And I'm a content writer.
I'm Gravity.
I'm 23.
I'm an engineer,
and I'm from Los Angeles.
- My name is Abe Valentino.
(upbeat music)
And I am 19 years old.
I'm originally from Los Angeles,
and I'm currently a nursing student,
as well as a social media influencer.
- You're in college?
What was like everyone's majors?
- Film.
I was psychology.
- Oh, I was English and screenwriting.
- Astrophysics.
- Okay, oh.
(Sierra laughing)
- So you're smarter.
- That's impressive.
(everyone laughing)
- The name Gravity's starting
to make a lot more sense now.
(everyone laughing)
- So what do you guys like to do for fun?
- I like traveling.
I like reading, eating ice cream.
- I like hanging out with my dogs.
I have two.
Kayaking, gardening, vegetarian grilling.
- Oh my gosh, I'm pescatarian.
- Okay, besties.
- I enjoy film photography,
hanging out with my friends,
and filming YouTube videos.
- Yeah well, here you are (laughs).
Makes sense.
- I like to lay around a lot,
but I also, like my main hobby is cosplay.
- Well, I like to watch a
lot of movies, you know.
Whether it's with friends
or just by myself, you know.
- Were you, oh, so sorry.
- No, I'm sorry.
- No, you can go first.
- Oh gosh.
- Literally go first.
- No, please go first.
- Are you sure?
- Yes.
- Do you want rock paper scissors for it?
- No.
- Okay, you sure?
- I kinda do now.
- Okay, let's do it.
- [Both] Rock, paper, scissors, shoot.
- Oh, okay then.
- Okay, you go first.
- Now, I feel bad, you go first (laughs).
- What were you guys' like,
cliques, in high school?
- Theater.
- Theater, oh, theater kid.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Were you like, more like, backstage,
or were you like performing?
- No, I acted in like, a lot of them,
but the last one I directed.
- What about you, Gravity?
- I was just kinda like
hanging out in the library
with the staff.
Like it just kinda felt like that.
So yeah.
- I was homeschooled,
so I took community college classes,
for junior and senior year.
So I was like sort of a
community college student,
sort of homeschooled so...
- Okay.
- What did you guys do
for your last birthday?
- Just me and a couple friends,
we went to a neighborhood bar,
and just had a couple drinks, yeah.
- I did kind of like the
similar thing because COVID.
It's like my last two birthdays
were not entirely what I wanted.
- What's like, ideal?
- I like to go do things.
Like I like activities.
What about you guys?
- I guess, I don't know.
I just wanna be outside.
- Yeah, I like to be by the ocean.
Maybe like a road trip.
- I feel like this one's
so like pick-me to say.
No, but pretty much
every birthday I've had,
has been a great birthday.
- Oh, but that's great though.
- My last birthday, my 19th birthday,
I ended up actually going
to New York with my sister,
for a couple days.
(Claire gasping)
And then I came back and went to a concert
with my best friend.
- What concert?
- Emo Night Tour.
(electric guitar strumming)
- Are you the person that
asks people to hang out?
Or are you the person that's
like, asked continuously,
to be like, to hang out with someone?
- It's more of a mutual thing
between me and my friends.
It's more of like, oh, so
we're hanging out today.
- Having like only one real close friend.
- Yeah.
- We'll throw out a bunch of ideas,
and then I'm just kinda like, all right,
so you tell me when you wanna do this,
'cause I wanna do this right now.
You let me know.
- I feel like I ask my friends,
but only my closest friends.
With other friends, yeah,
I never know whether I should ask,
or whether they're gonna ask me.
- I love to initiate things.
I always just like text my friends,
"Hey, you want to like,
go to that restaurant,
"we were talking about or--"
- [Claire] Yeah.
- "You wanna try that new spot?"
Usually they're busy,
which makes me feel like
I'm not doing enough things.
- You're perfect, Connor, it's okay.
You're perfect.
Do you feel like you have
like, a pretty wide range,
of friends that like you
would ask to go hang out with?
- Yeah, yeah, I would say so.
It's a wide range.
- Okay, I feel like I've learned a lot,
and nothing at the same time.
- No, same.
(everyone laughing)
- A good question to like go off of,
is everyone's like, first
impressions of each other.
- Okay, hi Connor.
You're kind of an enigma.
From the way that you talked,
you're much more extroverted
than I thought you would be.
You just, you do a lot.
You sound like you like,
love to be with people.
- I think you'd be like
more in the middle,
simply because of the fact
that you didn't talk as much,
as like the rest of the group.
You do sound like you do a
lot of things with people,
but I feel like you may not
be being completely honest.
- I'm gonna have to say
like, of this group,
I think you're probably at four.
- Oh, okay, so we're there now?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Now your turn.
- Oh.
- To be on the chopping block.
(Claire laughing)
- As the day progressed, you were like,
you know, you were in
charge of the conversation.
You were getting it going.
So I would say you're--
- Like one or two?
- Yeah, one or two.
- Okay.
- What you two are, probably
the top two (laughs).
- Okay.
- In terms of--
- Oh, so does like everyone
think we would be the top two?
- Yes.
- Like would anyone, okay.
- [Connor] Definitely.
- Well, is the rest of
the lineup, like, good?
- Actually, I think I
should move one more down.
- You think so?
- Yeah, because I observed,
that the conversation
usually starts by you.
- Mm.
- Second by you.
- Mm hmm.
- And then pass down
this line and back to me.
- Mm.
- So I think I should be at the tail end.
- So you think you and
Sierra should switch?
- I mean, I think I'm
either in four or five.
I just don't know which one?
- Okay.
- But I'm fine with switching.
- Oh no.
It's not that I don't think,
that you're less extroverted than Connor,
it's just I think that if Connor,
what he is saying is true,
he's going out with his
friends like the bars.
- He likes parties, I don't.
- And partying.
- That's fair (laughs).
- Yeah, it's just like,
I would say that someone more
extroverted would do that,
compared to someone more introverted.
- But I would argue though,
that extroverted people don't
inherently like to like,
go out to parties.
Like Connor could be telling us,
that he likes to go out with friends,
but maybe it's for like
two hours at a time.
- If I think I'm having fun at a party,
then I would stay for longer.
But I would never be the one,
to like dance in the
center of the dance floor,
'cause I don't want attention like that,
but I wanna have fun,
but I don't want attention.
- Okay.
- Can I get the first impression,
so that I can figure out what you--
- Oh yeah.
- Oh yeah, go for it.
- Yes.
First impressions of you?
- Okay, I really thought
you were gonna be lower
on the ranking.
Simply because you came in,
and you were just like super quiet.
And I was like, "Maybe she's introverted,
"but just has like good style."
But that was like the one thing,
that was like throwing me off.
I think like, after talking to you,
that you're in the right spot.
- So I don't know, you were
kind of like a bit of an enigma,
but it definitely looks like, you know,
that like you are on the
more extroverted side.
(upbeat rock music)
Like I feel like you're very confident--
(everyone laughing)
You know, you know (laughs).
I feel like you should be higher.
- Oh.
- [Claire] Personally.
- Do you think we should switch?
- Yes.
- Okay, do you wanna switch?
- Okay.
- Yeah, just because you kept
saying you love outdoors,
and also kayaking.
Do you do like single
kayak or do you do like--
- No, I have a tandem kayak.
You could fit two and a half people.
- You got friends.
(everyone laughing)
You got friends.
- Maybe...
- You think they should back?
- I'm not sure.
- I think we should switch back.
- I was thinking that too,
but I just didn't wanna say anything.
I was like...
- Cut that out, cut that out.
I was wrong.
(everyone laughing)
- No, I just,
not that I don't think that
you're more extroverted.
- Just slow move, slow move.
- It's just, I dunno.
- It's just, you make it
obvious you're extroverted.
And I don't think it's obvious--
- Who?
- You do.
- I do? Wait.
- No, no, no, not like
you make it obvious.
- I was like what?
- No, no, no, I feel
like it's more obvious.
- Okay.
- For us to be like for first impressions,
to say that you're more extroverted.
But for me I was like,
"Oh, I got you guessing."
- Yeah, no you definitely
caught me off guard.
For sure.
- Okay.
- So are we like happy with this lineup?
- I don't know.
I feel like Connor might
be trying to throw us off.
I'm not sure, I've--
- Which is why I think you should--
(everyone laughing)
- I don't know,
but now I feel like I'm
overthinking everything.
I guess I feel comfortable with
you guys staying like that.
- Sure.
- Yeah, do you feel like
you're the first one though?
- Yes.
- Okay.
(Sierra laughing)
Do you feel comfortable where you are?
- Yes.
- Do you feel comfortable where you are?
- Yes, do you feel comfortable?
(everyone laughing)
- (laughs) My ego tells me
I need to be number one,
but no, I don't think I'm number one.
- I don't think I should be number one.
- Ooh.
- Oh, okay.
(Claire laughing)
No, do you wanna switch?
- Do you wanna switch?
Do you wanna rock paper scissors?
- If that's how you wanna solve that,
we totally can but--
- I don't know.
- No, I'm comfortable in this
position right here, or there.
I literally don't care.
- Switch.
- Okay.
- Okay, confident, confident.
We'll switch-a-roo.
- Okay, so we think this is the--
- This is the--
- This is it?
- Yes.
(upbeat music)
- [Interviewer] First off,
let's have Gravity switch with Claire.
Let's have Connor switch with Claire.
And then, let's have
Sierra switch with Claire.
- [Sierra] You were behind him.
- [Man] This is most
introverted to most extroverted.
(woman laughing)
- Okay, so she lied to us.
- Yeah I know.
- I did not lie.
- I wish I had more clue
about what was going on.
(everyone laughing)
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- I did not expect Claire
to be most introverted.
Especially because she kind of was like,
guiding most of the conversations.
- She just really seemed
extroverted to me.
- My Myers-Briggs
personality type is ENTP.
- I have ENTJ.
- I have ENFJ.
- I'm INFJ.
- And I am INFP.
(gentle upbeat music)
So I did not lie (laughs).
I come off very extroverted.
I'm really capable of like
holding a conversation,
and like talking to people.
But like on the inside
I just get really tired.
My anxiety just like holds me back a bit,
just because of like
past events in my life.
In college, I experienced a
pretty abusive relationship,
that really kind of beat me
down and heightened my anxiety.
I got like panic attacks and everything.
And now I'm kind of scared
to go certain places,
and just like to do certain things.
So I think it's definitely impacted,
just like how I navigate everything.
Which sucks, but I'm
learning to come to terms,
with like who I am now.
- This is not what I expected.
- Yeah.
- Like at all.
- I like dress very colorful
to like express myself better.
So that's like a big reason
why a lot of people think
that like I'm super extroverted,
and I like to be out
and going all the time.
But this is just a way for me to like,
another form of communication,
when sometimes it's too
hard for me to do that.
- When I first came in here,
I thought for sure you were
gonna be all the way up here.
(Claire laughing)
So like, I just, I guess
it was just more of like,
this sounds so corny,
you can't judge a book by its cover.
- Yeah.
- But like that's
literally what we did here,
and then turned out completely different.
- [Interviewer] Do you like
to recharge with people
or by yourself?
- With people.
- Takes me a long time to burn out.
Let's just put it that way.
- I have this answer prepared.
I like to wear my comfiest leggings,
my fuzzy socks,
and I like to have a
pint of Ben and Jerry's,
or cheesy popcorn,
and either like watch
a movie or read a book.
That's what I like to do (laughs).